scl ml Chau
af 4 a Blue Do
Boo Boo s Fare
I think it's
a sense of accomplishment, so I think there are various things in the sense of accomplishment, but one is to clear that
boss or defeat the goal.  There is a sense of accomplishment that I'm going, but
anders 4 me to do
meme r Base good underle 2
voodoo Originally Anoucher Star Program Marker Hardware
Gesture
Spoo We used it as a
designer designer or I was an industrial designer.  And
those people who are called artists are leading the
pou dou dou
story jer Puffer Lesser. That's why
I show the situation of what to do to create that motive. Well, if it's Mario,
right right.  If you run, you'll have a goal. If you're a Donkicom, you
'll be kidnapped or climb up to that point to help Kagojo.
After all, I feel
like I'm a hero I feel like I'm really crying.
Am ende Game Arrestififty
the first wing New a las Well good to do me
Game pou dou dou
Well, the point is  I'm thinking about it, but I'm thinking about it and discussing it with my friends, but after
all, for example, in Super Mario games, we're making it because we think it's much more interesting
.
It's difficult because it's difficult
[Music]
durata resor Double to do
voodoo It's said that it was possible to play various ways from first-time players to advanced players.
Norbert Houdru
[Music]